Disney is dying and it's easy to see why
between the back-to-back flops burning
money to supply Disney plus and films
that just miss the mark Disney is in
trouble but today I've got the solution
and the answer that the house and mouse
is looking for is a right here on
YouTube
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that won't charge you 27
million dollars a year to fix your
problems how's that for cost savings
there Bob Iger have you noticed that a
lot of movies have bombed recently fast
X underperformed The Flash is looking
like it'll lose 200 million dollars to
Warner Brothers making it the biggest
comic book movie bomb ever even
objectively great films like Mission
Impossible dead reckoning one fell short
of expectations this summer but the
biggest victim of the box office
bloodbath for the last two years has got
to be our Mouse eared overlords at Walt
Disney Corp Doctor Strange 2 Thor 3 and
Black Panther 2 all came in under
expectations The Little Mermaid vastly
underperformed both Ant-Man 3 and new
Indiana Jones were also costly losers no
one even remembers Disney's last
animated feature film Strange World and
Elemental had the lowest opening of any
modern Pixar film ever including light
year the massive bomb that was released
right before it the long and short of
all of this things are bad at the house
of mouse right now Disney Shares are at
the lowest that they've been since covet
hit back in March of 2020 and to turn it
all around they're considering selling
off their TV businesses spitting off
ESPN laying off thousands of employees
we are truly witnessing the death of the
Disney Empire happening in real time
right now but I think that there's a way
to fix things and the key to it all is
YouTube so grab your popcorn as I
prepare to tell you a story far more
compelling than anything's put out over
the last few years it's time to fix
Disney in three easy steps but before I
help a large soulless Corporation earn
its Millions back won't you help our
small Soulful Corporation here earn some
thousands back you can help do that by
checking out our new line of theory
where this isn't just merch these are
actual clothes made specifically with
you and your life in mind designed to
last for years and created to help you
feel amazing these items are cozy
they're comfortable but they're also
fashionable case in point if you love
analog horror then no clip your way out
of the back rooms and into our Hazmat
puffer jacket never before has biohazard
protection been so snuggly then pair
that puffer with the radioactive
backpack to keep all your dangerous
bacteria life forms safely contained as
you walk the streets or if you're
looking for some infrared realness check
out the heat map collection black
clothing with intense pops of color take
your pick of shorts hoodies work jackets
even socks and for the fashion that's
truly fire check out the new
thermoreactive tea and mug which can
both change color as they heat up but if
all of those are a bit too loud for your
closet check out the hi-res button up on
the outside it looks like your typical
high quality white shirt but inside the
collar inner button lining and cuffs all
have a classic game theory green
high-tech circuit board design now if
only it came in red one day film Theory
one day we have all of this and more at
our brand new theoryware website which
you should go check out by clicking the
link in the description below or by
checking out the merch shelf just below
this video even if you don't want to buy
anything just go check out the site it's
actually really cool with some fun
surprises hidden inside of it this year
we're just really pushing ourselves to
do bigger more interesting things in the
style where probably because we have
Channel now and I think honestly this is
a great first step in that so go check
out all the awesome new fashionable
merch that we have on the website and
hey who knows maybe one day we'll open
up a theorist store all to ourselves at
the local mall here there's quite a few
vacant Disney locations that could use
some new tenants speaking of let's talk
more about that Disney dilemma shall we
basically when you break it all down
Disney's problems largely boil down to
three major topics streaming budget and
story so let's go through them Point by
Point starting with streaming one thing
that everyone tends to overlook when
they first start a streaming service is
that you need a steady flow of content
to make it work to keep people hooked on
the platform and making content tends to
be expensive hence the elongated merch
push they just went through but even if
you thread the needle and manage to
solve both of those issues making lots
of content for a relatively cheap price
it just opens a well of new issues that
are more difficult to solve let me
explain to prevent people from bouncing
off the platform most of Disney's Star
Studios have been relegated to content
factories to feed the Disney plus
machine in 2020 Disney held an investor
Day presentation with had Marvel and
lucasfilm announced 10 projects each and
Pixar announced another six it wasn't
all streaming Focus but a whole lot of
it was in addition the service has been
flooded with Disney dipping into all its
other major IPS live action remakes of
Peter Pan serialized versions of High
School Musical the return of nostalgic
Classics like Willow and the launch of
anticipated new IP like Artemis Fowl
Disney owns some of the most beloved IP
on the planet and they've been pulling
it all off the shelves to try and keep
their content offering on Disney plus
robust and most importantly sticky keep
all those finicky streaming audiences
that are quick to cancel a subscription
despite it being difficult and expensive
to stand that online content treadmill
at least on the surface it looks like
Disney managed to thread the needle but
in achieving that they've actually
exposed themselves to a problem that's
far worse brand dilution there's no
arguing that pretty much every single
one of these cherished franchises has
become significantly less special over
the last five years simply because
there's just so much of them around at
this point Toy Story 4 light year Toy
Story 5. you can only go to the pump so
many times times before the audience can
smell a Shameless cash grab going back
to those investor day announcements most
of the Star Wars ones they were quietly
canceled a completely different episode
9 a Boba Fett Solo movie A Trilogy from
Ryan Johnson another Trilogy from The
Game of Thrones guys when something new
from Star Wars gets announced at this
point there's little trust that it's
ever going to see the light of day and
even less trust that it's gonna be good
and or for instance it was legitimately
great seriously it was the single best
thing that Star Wars has produced in
years I know why no one watched it
because it was buried under a slew of
underwhelming projects like the book of
Boba Fett Obi-Wan Kenobi late season
Mandalorian in episode nine people lost
trust with the brand and as a result
de-prioritized watching all the new
stuff that was rolling out the MCU is
having the exact same issue right now
look at this phase one had 746 minutes
of content spread over five years phase
two 757 minutes spread over three years
and then he had phase three at 1 500
minutes spread over another three years
that was a pretty significant jump but
it was nothing thing compared to phase
four thanks in part to the introduction
to Disney plus and the requirement for
streaming content phase 4 had a
staggering 3 500 minutes spread across
only two years there's been more MCU
content in the last two years than the
preceding 12 combined a Marvel release
used to feel like an event like you had
to see it nowadays though it's quite
literally a weekly occurrence so of
course people are going to be less
excited for new installments like secret
Invasion regardless of their quality
don't worry we're gonna address the
quality here in a second what's worse in
their drive to Disney plus the mouse has
lost out on a lot of money they probably
didn't need to looking at the list of
original films created and released by
Disney so many of them are going
straight to Disney Plus without making
any money in a theater this year alone
across all their Studios six of the 14
Disney films so far have premiered
directly on Disney Plus or Hulu with no
additional cost in 2022 a whopping 27
premiered on streaming and only 16 were
in theaters now compare all that to 2018
the year before Disney plus launched
where Disney released faced only 10
films total all of which obviously went
to the theaters Not only do these
streaming premieres mean that they're
losing a lot of money from the
theatrical window but it becomes an even
bigger issue when you combine it with
our next major problem budgeting the
budgets for so many modern Blockbusters
and especially those made by Disney are
just out of control Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny cost 300 million
dollars to make Guardians 3 in The
Little Mermaid 250 million dollars each
quantumania a cool 200 mil they even
spent 150 million dollars on Haunted
Mansion why would you spend 150 million
dollars on a Haunted Mansion movie and
the true number is probably more like
300 million if you include the marketing
for it even Disney's animation Wing
isn't safe both in Kanto and Strange
World cost somewhere between 135 and 180
million dollars to make while almost all
of Pixar's latest releases put their
budgets between 150 and 200 in range now
you might be looking at all those
numbers and thinking wow that's a lot
but aren't all movies super expensive
and the answer is yes but also no yeah
they cost hundreds of millions of
dollars but not many hundreds of
millions of dollars when you look at
other massive Blockbusters currently in
theaters most are not looking like this
Oppenheimer had a massive cast and
incredible experimental filmmaking
techniques and it cost just a hundred
million dollars to make John Wick 4
elaborate action sequences with top tier
stunt work and incredible set designs at
multiple real world locations also costs
just a hundred million dollars Barbie is
the biggest movie of The Summer it has
iconic art Direction detailed fictional
worlds with real sets and A-list actors
who enjoyed being there and it was made
for less than 150 million dollars over
on the animation side the newly released
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles movie cost
70 million while Puss in Boots the last
wishing across the spider-verse and the
Super Mario Brothers movie were all at
about 100 Mil each all of these are half
to a third of what Disney has planned to
make their movies and it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to understand that it's
a lot easier to get back what you put in
when you're only 70 million dollars in
the hole as opposed to 200 million all
of this begs the question of why though
why are these movies so expensive well
it's complicated in a then ultimately
comes down to a lot of different factors
and over Reliance on CGI a push to
develop new technologies writing that
just doesn't keep budgets in mind but
one of the biggest contributors to the
inflation of a movie's budget over at
Disney that a lot of people don't talk
about are reshoots a reshoot is where a
film brings back the cast and crew to
re-film scenes that didn't work or to
film new scenes that become needed as
they get into the editing process don't
get me wrong reshoots are a perfectly
normal part of production and they can
really help bring a movie together a lot
of very successful films have had
reshoots Back to the Future E.T Rocky
that's not the sort of stuff I'm talking
about here what I'm talking about is
when a movie studio sees the rough cut
of a movie gets cold feet and then
suddenly decides they basically need to
start over from scratch probably the
most famous example of this was with
Zack Snyder's Justice League but Disney
they too have been guilty of this a lot
lately most publicly with solo a Star
Wars story originally that movie was
directed by Phil Lord and Chris Miller
the two guys behind spiderverse in The
Lego Movie but Disney didn't like what
they saw and so they hired Ron Howard to
reshoot an estimated 80 percent of the
movie thereby doubling its budget to
somewhere around 300 million dollars now
as we all know solo did not do super
well it only grossed about 400 million
dollars worldwide a number that suddenly
becomes a lot less painful to look at if
your original budget was just 125
million but all the streaming and
budgeting changes in the world are going
to be useless if they continue to fail
at our third main point story so many
Disney films lately have been failing at
making a story that's both worth telling
and that audiences want to hear Disney
keeps hoping that you can still slap a
brand name onto something and it'll sell
but that just doesn't work anymore
audiences aren't stupid they can tell
when a story is being told just because
the bean counters think it's gonna make
money like who asked for zootopia 2
Frozen 3 Inside Out 2 Toy Story 5. all
of those are real movies that are
happening in the near future even though
it feels like that list should be a
parody but making unnecessary sequels is
just the tip of the iceberg Disney also
doesn't understand where their stories
fit anymore look no further than the
eternals which introduced a dozen new
characters and 10 000 years of back
story into a two-hour film why wasn't
this a Disney plus series that could
have given the concept time to breathe
meanwhile they're clearly stretching out
stories that don't need to be TV shows
the Obi-Wan series is a great example of
this there was a really strong core
narrative there about Obi-Wan's
relationship to Vader that ultimately
got buried under the bloatware of side
quests and subplots and hey wouldn't you
know it Obi-Wan was originally written
to be a two-hour film that they decided
to turn into a six hour series if you
want a super recent example secret
Invasion which man I have no idea what
Marvel was thinking on this one let's
take this iconic storyline from the
comics with an Avengers level threat and
adapted into a spy Thriller with
basically no spying no thrills and no
Avengers what should have been this
amazing tentpole moment in The Avengers
line of films I mean who doesn't love
themselves a good imposter storyline
became yet another piece of wasted
potential content to further dilute the
MCU brand on Disney plus and again
here's the problem when you start
dumping out a lot of content all at once
just to keep us on the digital treadmill
people start to see Pat patterns they
see the trends the formulas that you're
using for example I have so many big
Temple Disney releases lately had a main
character becoming jaded just because
they lost a loved one it happened with
Han Solo Luke Skywalker Indiana Jones
Obi-Wan Kenobi heck even Haunted Mansion
and secret Invasion which you probably
should know because why would you ever
bother to see those things this
generation of stories has seen our
fictional Heroes become miserable and
let's be real that is not something that
fans want to see we fell in love with
these characters for a reason they
inspired us for a reason seeing them
crushed under the same depression of
reality that we real people face every
day is not fun sure it might be more
realistic to see a disillusioned Indiana
Jones but audiences go to the movies to
escape from reality to believe in
something better something greater to
have something to hope for and aspire to
and Disney is no longer providing those
hopeful messages so that's a lot of Doom
and Gloom right is there any way that
Disney and really the entire film
industry can fix all these issues well
yeah actually all you gotta do treat it
like a YouTube channel what I mean to
say is that they need to program their
slate of movies just like you do a
YouTube channel I'm gonna let you in on
a little secret here loyal theorists we
spend a lot of time thinking about what
theories we put up across all the
different channels with multiple weekly
meetings trying to figure out what would
work best where planning out when things
should go up and what videos complement
each other all for the overall health of
the business you can't just throw up a
video willy-nilly and hope everything
goes well these days no you need to make
sure that you have solid videos here and
there to keep the system and your
viewers happy and everything we talked
about today with Disney are things that
regularly come up in our day-to-day
conversations about how to run things
here at theorists first of all we have a
quality bar that episodes just have to
hit otherwise they're not going to get
made our primary metric in the successor
failure of a video isn't Revenue it's
actually you the community could we make
more money by pumping out more episodes
every week probably but in the process
we would burn you out and by necessity
dilute the show as we green light worse
and worse episodes see in YouTube
analytics they give you a handy little
chart ranking your most recent releases
from 1 to 10 in terms of how well it's
performing well ideally every upload you
do is going to be a one out of ten
that's just not realistic to have that
sort of expectation in the end something
is inevitably gonna be a 10 out of 10.
and if you're good at what you do you
know when those nines and tens are gonna
hit and so you have to surround that low
performer with stuff that you know is
gonna do well otherwise you risk taking
L after L after L and you start making a
narrative about how bad your stuff is
now how much it's fallen off or Worse
the algorithm decides that people no
longer care about your channel apply
this concept to Disney and you
immediately see what they have to do
with their IP when you have back to back
to back to back disappointments line up
like in Marvel's recent roster it
creates a downward spiral that's pretty
hard to break in the public
Consciousness but if you mix in one or
two goods with the bad strategically
Suddenly It's much harder to craft a
doom and gloom narrative here's an
example programming lineup Multiverse
Madness wakanda forever Guardians 3 love
and thunder quantumania that looks a lot
different from what really happened
where Guardians 3 appeared at the end
the real release order gave you four
disappointments in a row before you got
a small pick-me-up with a generally
well-received Guardian but if Guardians
had been in the middle the
disappointments are suddenly broken up
there's a gap there the lackluster
movies on either side of it it's just a
franchise coast and long waiting for the
next big event in fact I can make this
programming lineup even better if
wakanda forever had actually been first
in the list the mediocre performance of
wakanda actually was made significantly
worse by the disappointment of
Multiverse Madness that came directly
before had it come before doctor strange
that movie wouldn't have been saddled
with all the extra scrutiny of his
Marvel losing its way if wakanda forever
isn't good it means it's the end of
Marvel thereby leading to a different
cultural conversation around it release
order matters when it comes to shaping
The Narrative around your brand and it
matters a lot the same thing holds true
for any experimental episodes Disney
needs to be making films about new IP
like Pixar's Elio or lesser known
characters like Marvel's Moon Knight but
obviously those projects are going to be
risky so you balance that risk out by
putting them between other projects you
expect to do well your Toy Story fives
your Avengers your Guardians this
accomplishes three things all at once
you mitigate your risk you spread out
the quote-unquote cash grabs and you
potentially find your next explosive IP
again let's look at film theory for an
example on this channel we have a few
relatively sure things our tentpole
programming analog horror Spider-Man
nostalgic kid shows and knowing that
we're able to put the stuff that we're
not sure about between them and then if
something surprises you and it does
manage to explode bam you have yourself
a new strong subject to slot other
unknowns in between that is literally
what happened to us with the back rooms
we weren't sure how that one was gonna
do and it ended up doing gangbusters
with people wanting more and more of our
analysis videos while they wear their
new absurdly comfortable Theory where
Hazmat puffer jackets the gamble paid
off and it paid off in a big way but we
also know that we can't release too many
of those things in too quick of
succession we can't release a backrooms
theory every single week because even
though they'll do well people will
eventually stop caring if we do too much
and they'll stop coming back because
we're no longer adding anything to the
conversation does that sound familiar
Star Wars how about you Marvel you
relate and just in general when running
a YouTube channel you got to know what
episode ideas are going to work best as
shorts and which ones Merit a full video
we don't try to take something that's
clearly as short and then bloated into a
full 15 minute video or vice versa just
like Disney shouldn't be looking at
something that's clearly an hour and a
half movie and trying to turn it into a
10 episode mini series just so they get
more watch minutes on their streaming
app content needs to fit where it tells
the best story lastly in terms of our
budgeting we have to make sure that an
episode can make back the money that
we're spending on making it paying the
writers and editors that are working on
it and we budget it just based on the
AdSense we expect to make from that
video anything extra that we get from
Brand deals or merch sales or whatever
it's a nice plus it allows us to expand
the team to do more ambitious projects
but we can't budget every single video
that way because eventually we're gonna
lose that bet and we can't run the
business anymore think of our AdSense
like your box office Disney sure every
now and then we could do a more
expensive video something that takes a
bit more time or just invest in a
passion project that's going to be maybe
a once or twice a year thing not in
every release thing Disney you can't
keep releasing 300 million dollar movie
after 300 million dollar movie without
knowing that you're gonna earn that back
at the box office budget according to
what You Know You're Gonna earn in the
theaters that way all the ancillary
stuff that's all gravy anything you earn
on top of that boom it's a bonus you
became that much more profitable you
know what's gonna help with that fixing
your reshoot issue let me tell you as I
was researching this episode just as
someone running a media company my jaw
hit the floor when I saw how often
companies like Disney are doing reshoots
that majorly overhaul the movie how are
you rolling on day one without having a
Clear Vision that the writers directors
producers in studio have all agreed to a
theorist we don't do an episode unless
all of our senior creative team are on
the same page about what that episode's
gonna be and more importantly when we
work with Brands we require that every
single stakeholder review and lock the
script before shooting begins that way
no one can ask for a last minute change
we learned early that those reshoots and
re-edits cost a fortune killing our
process but by forcing everyone to get
on the same page early even if it's
painful and slows the process down a bit
at the beginning it saves so much time
money and a ton of headaches on the
other much more expensive end of the
production process all in all in their
desperate bid to try to catch up to
Netflix with their streaming service
throwing money at their problems in
hopes that they'll go away Disney lost
sight of what made entertainment work
since the very beginning making what you
can making what you're good at keeping
it on budget and telling a story that's
worth telling and if we here on YouTube
can do it they have no excuse or if they
can't get their act together maybe the
death of Disney was ultimately for the
best but hey remember go check out that
new line of theory where again I cannot
stress enough just how much work went
into all these items because we wanted
this to be more than just your typical
YouTuber merch like well just slap the
logo on it no these are actual clothing
items that have high quality Fabrics
expert details and stuff that's going to
make you feel incredible when you wear
it so please do me a favor go check out
all the cool stuff that we made by
heading on over to our theoryware
website link is in the description below
or maybe it's on screen right now I
don't know maybe through the magic of
editing we can make that happen
and as always my friends until next time
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and cut